the White House acting more like
Hunter's defense attorney questions are
growing over what the hell the Biden
family did in order to secure a million
dollars in payments in Chinese cash gee
I wonder if it was the powerful last
name Hunter has already admitted he took
the money after Republicans made bank
records public but that's not stopping
Kareem Jean-Pierre from accusing
Republicans of lying about it
a house oversight says they've got bank
records showing a Chinese Energy company
paying three Biden family members
through a third party what were they
paid for look I'm just not going to
respond to that from here it look it we
have heard from House Republicans for
years in years and years
how uh how the inaccuracies and lies
when it comes to this issue and I don't
even where to begin to even answer that
question because again it's been lies
and lies and inaccuracy for the past
couple years and I'm just not going to
get into it from here
well she's just not going to get into it
Greg but it's been years and years of
the Republicans lying but that comes as
no surprise because Biden staffers have
been working as Hunter's personal PR
firm for a long time newly released
emails from 2015 show then Vice
President Biden's office tried to kill a
news story about Hunter
all right so Greg they're all lies and
they're trying to kill stories I mean I
thought the White House didn't get
involved in political this is such
torture I mean we find out that Hunter
has a mole I mean in the FBI well I was
just thinking I've seen the video he's
got five but I mean but his mole's name
is one eye I mean what are you trying to
do to us
like it's like you
but if I write I say them I'm gonna get
fired I wish I'm so jealous I you know
basically he's making he's raising
Millions using his name as a way to
introduce people I want to do this with
Dana you know if you want to meet Dana
and I'm saying this to the audience if
you want to meet Dana I need some good
faith seed money all right good faith
seed money I'll make it happen right
I'll drive you to her house you won't
mind but this sheer skullduggery would
make a Gravedigger jealous this is stuff
again if you imagine a republican doing
stuff like this we there's even
Mulligans that we don't talk about that
we gave him like you know when he tried
to pin the discarded firearm on it
illegals remember he said that and his
casual use of the n-word with his dealer
and then telling his brother's widow to
get an AIDS test these I mean there's so
many things that it's almost hard to
keep up but you have to keep your eye on
the prize and the eye is the corruption
and the corruption connection to the
it's a Syndicate you know her dad all
the he's he's The Rainmaker for his dad
it's a crime syndicate it's been going
on forever you know and now we're seeing
it you know Jesse why does the White
House think that they can do this that
they can get away with it knowing that
there's a money trail that there's bank
records that this stuff is really if you
can finally get it which we finally did
it's pretty clear they think they can
get away with it because there's only
one Fox News if ducey's the only one
asking her the question she can skate if
everyone's asking her the same question
the bidens are toast it's like Jenga hey
play this with Jesse Jr it's like how
many things can you pull out and watch
this thing still stand it's unbelievable
at this point but the binder is in a
bind because if she says what Hunter
says the Chinese paid them well then
she's calling her boss a liar but if she
says what her boss said that it never
happened then she's a liar so she just
says nothing and she's if she gets away
with it and then you have emails a paper
trail going back 10 years that the Biden
communication shop has been burying
Hunter Biden's stories forever and now
this guy's got a one-eyed mole in the
FBI we call them the furry Cyclops and
and and the guy that was he used the
furry Cyclops to tell the guy that
bribed them with the eighty thousand
dollar Diamond to get out of the country
because the feds were coming
you know when you when you hear this
kind of thing Dana and you know the
White House Press office going as strong
as she did singing the lies and the
Republicans and all that I mean they are
don't they look the uh Shakespeare said
they don't protest too much oh yeah yeah
that could be definitely a problem for
them and she had been fairly disciplined
for a long time to say no comment we're
not coming there's an investigation call
over there and they have I mentioned him
the other day and Sams he's the
spokesperson at the White House
counsel's office now he's the one who's
been basically blocking and tackling and
actually punching pretty sharply uh and
and Landing some blows sometimes from
the White House council's office so I
don't know why she didn't just say Peter
you got to call Ian Sam's you know you
know his number I'm not answering it
from here because as soon as you answer
it from the podium well now you own it
and you can't put that toothpaste back
in the tube or the horse back in the
barn whatever we want to say but let's
also go back to 10 years ago when the
staff of the Biden white Vice
president's office
is in a position of having to take these
calls these calls come it doesn't matter
go back the Reagan's dealt with this in
terms of uh children that questions
about relationships with virtual then
you had George H.W bush right there was
a question when the Savings and Loan
crisis happened Neil bush like okay we
got to ask about that remember uh Jimmy
Carter had a situation the clintons had
a situation with a relative and then
their own situation
it puts the I think that what happens in
this case with this particular one is
that the staff is in a very difficult
position because President Biden wants
his son defended on some of these things
his son does not deserve to be defended
and if you look back to some of the
emails that we know that were happening
in the Obama white house where they were
emailing to each other saying uh guys
have you seen like are you worried I
think I'm worried we shouldn't I don't
think Hunter what and they're nervous
about it but the president has never
given them an off ramp because he
demands
complete fealty to him and to Hunter you
know Jessica what Dane is talking about
is there is a an email where to
schwerwin who is the president of
Rosemont Seneca that's now defunct she's
done everything she can to not use it um
and they're referring to Kate Bennington
telling bettingfield uh to tell telling
the Bloomberg people yeah so Kate
batting field actually just left
recently and she's been in Biden world
for ages and when I read the email
exchange you could sense her frustration
coming off the page right like this is
not what I signed up for right I signed
up to work with Joe Biden everyone knows
who he is right someone who has this
long reputation is getting things done
and this isn't their job it's it's not
Korean John Pierre's job that's why they
got Ian Sam's to do this and I think
that to go beyond what Dana was saying
about how President Biden wants his son
defended
there's a disconnect between how serious
he thinks the issue is and the reality
of it not necessarily because I think
that this is a crime syndicate because I
really don't think that but
we got paid by the same person okay
um
voters Democrats are not going to not
vote for Joe Biden over this unless a
crime syndicate is proven but it's the
little gnawing things that just bug you
where you're like why do I have to deal
with this right why are these stories
coming out and why is there no cohesive
narrative against it and that's what
Aaron Burnett brought up on her show
earlier in the week which said here's a
lay person and you're looking at this
you're
kind of stinky right what's happening
here and what would the narrative be
yeah well if there was some declaration
where you don't even have to say my son
is completely corrupt in any way but
just to say I never personally profited
from this because that's what people
voted for Joe Biden yes I don't know
it's not true I well I don't know it
seems like there are a lot of
inconsistencies floating around from
what Hunter has said versus what the
president is maintained and I hope
that's because they don't align each
other but it's not it's not enough to
say I didn't personally profit if your
entire family is profiting that's
okay so we are at the center of it we
all know about nepotism right I don't
need to do the Schoolhouse Rock about
that there are a lot of very powerful
families where brothers and sisters and
spouses and kids are this is the same
Saudi every China runs every the CCP
runs every business in China yeah yeah I
understand I just agreed with everyone
about bike dance and Tick Tock here but
I'm saying that to make it out as if
this is the first family that has ever
profited off of an autocracy that we
despise is completely dishonest so don't
do that people make money in Russia they
make money in Saudi they make money in
China they make in money but it's how
they're making money there's no
legitimate business here these are all
foreign bribes yeah and you know other
than Islam seed money and good faith
Jesse that's right yeah and you can get
a meeting with Dana I just want to know
that they should ask for the tax how did
they pay taxes that's where you get it
that's always where they get them yeah
everyone and Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now